[Music]
hello and thanks for being with us the
chancellor nadeem zahawi has told sky
news that nobody should be cut off this
winter because they can't afford to pay
their energy bills in an exclusive
interview with k burley he accused
russia of using energy to divide western
countries but said the uk must continue
to support ukraine now one think tank
has warned this morning that soaring
inflation and energy bills will plunge
three million more people into poverty
mr zahavi pledged that there would be
additional help for struggling families
but will have to wait until the new
conservative leader is chosen on monday
to find out what that help will be now
he was speaking while on a visit to
washington where the government is
working on plans with the united states
to stop vladimir putin profiteering from
high oil prices
the people that are hurting um
significantly at the moment are the
people of the united kingdom um how much
longer can we afford to support the
battle in ukraine
well i think if we don't
uh continue to support
ukraine in this battle
against putin against this illegal
invasion the price will be much greater
to pay
i am certain of that which is why we
have to remain
resolute we have to coordinate
if you look at what
chancellor schultz is doing in germany
where germany was much more dependent on
uh russian
energy
uh of course other countries in europe
what is happening in the united states
this is something that we all have to to
deal with we
welcomed vladimir zielinski to
parliament had him beamed in live the
prime minister stood at the dispatch box
and actually reminded the nation
that you know there is uh you know more
uh to come in terms of what we need to
do not just the
help in terms of weapons and aid but we
need to be resolute and remember why
we're doing this there is war on our
continent you know very few people
predicted there will be war and wars
happened in far-flung places
and our response now
our ability to stay strong of course we
have to make sure
as chancellor as a government we help
those families that need the help target
that help tell me what that looks like
well
at the moment
mid-way of spending about 37 billion
yeah but it's not enough chance of
course it's not which is what i'm gonna
do the moment i walked into the treasury
on the fifth of july i gathered my
leadership team i said one um
how are we doing on delivering the help
because
it's one thing to announce it very
different to get it into people's
accounts
and there was a big focus on that but
equally importantly i said we need to
prepare options for the incoming prime
minister because if you think about the
help we're putting in you know tell me
what those options look like i'm about
to take you through so if you think
about what we're putting in now
um the most vulnerable eight million
households will get 1200 pounds um
everyone will get 400 pounds off their
bill
that really sort of helps with about 50
of this additional increase with the
energy price guy going up that's been
announced between october and december i
need to begin to think about what
happens in january and then in the rest
of next year you should begin to think
surely you've already been thinking
about it of course what i what i meant
is is
we have to deliver four people tell me
what it looks like
so
there's nothing off the table we're
looking at all the options
everything from the chief executive of
scottish power talking about um you know
help where uh
you know we need to to maybe
create a some sort of a a fund for
companies to be able to continue to help
their customers all the way through to
making sure that we target the help to
both households and small and
medium-sized businesses and probably
some larger businesses because my one of
my concerns is
the scarring effect on the economy if
perfectly viable businesses in
hospitality and
leisure in high energy use businesses
would actually suffer or
no longer exist because of putin's
um
use of energy as a as a weapon you said
that you were looking at two separate
plans depending on who was prime
minister how did they differ
well no what we
i think our responsibility is to make
sure we look at the pledges being made
by the different candidates um so uh
list trust uh has pledged to have a
moratorium on the green levees um do you
support that that would that it
certainly is something that i think will
help uh everyone it's about 150 pounds
of additional help so we've worked up
those options i said general taxation
then wouldn't you well there is
uh
hedwig
well not necessarily because actually we
have some headroom
at the moment certainly if you look at
uh on the capital side of the balance
sheet we've got some header i've got to
make sure i put all those on there are
no easy options um that's the one thing
we know because to clarify other two
separate plans depending on who's prime
minister no what we're doing is is
making sure we we
look at the pledges from both candidates
but also look at everything else that
we've been told by the energy sector so
i had the energy companies come in to
talk about things like liquidity in the
wholesale market and working with the
bank of england uh to look at how we can
provide better liquidity in the
wholesale market for energy they tell me
that would actually help with about four
to five hundred pounds
of reduction in the
energy price cap
look at
those companies that are generating wind
power and nuclear power but getting paid
at gas prices can we enter an agreement
with them for
a voluntary
contract for differences called cfd um
at a lower price now because they
they're not doing anything differently
in their business and they're making
very large profits it's all tinkering
though no that's not that's actually a a
quite a a significant uh piece of work
but that won't be ready till next winter
exactly but we have to make sure we get
the help
the additional help from january onwards
so what's the next round of support
looking like in numbers
so
again what i'm not going to do here
it'll be irresponsible of a chancellor
uh to begin uh to uh talk numbers before
a new prime minister
is i've got to give them those options
sure so you know what the numbers are
decisions no what i'm what i'm saying to
you is um it would be irresponsible i
think liz trust was right on this she's
not going to set a budget
during a campaign
she'd need to look at the detail i would
need to present her those details
and of course then she will need to make
a decision what my responsibilities is
to help her hit the ground running and
that i pledge to you and your viewers we
will do how concerned are you that
people are going to
freeze from the cold this winter at home
because they can't afford to afford to
put their energy on i'm deeply concerned
i mean those people on pre-pay meters
i've we've got to make sure we that's
why i go back and say to you
my my preference is targeting the help
um you know labor have talked about sort
of a universal uh uh piece of help that
would cost about
but when i ask you you're targeting it
you won't tell me so when will we know
no what i'm saying to you is actually
it's better to target the help for those
families that really need it as we're
doing now with the 8 million families
getting 1200 pounds
target it for smes so hospitality high
energy use sectors maybe some larger
businesses who are also um uh finding it
very difficult when your energy bill has
gone up by three and a half times four
times it's very difficult to be able to
sustain your uh business and i don't
want to see that scarring effect that we
could be left with
in the economy
so all that work we will make sure is
ready for the incoming prime minister um
that's the right thing to do and then of
course in the longer term
we have an energy strategy that ensures
that we have that involves nuclear
resilience very much involves nuclear it
involves offshore wind it involves of
course tidal energy i went to visit a
company in scotland that has actually
commercialized uh tidal energy the
beauty of tidal energy is actually you
can use it for base load because you can
predict the tide unlike wind and sun
tidal energy is is is reasonably
predictable so
lots of investment in
offshore wind we've seen an increase in
our gas production by about twenty six
percent this year because of the
policies that qazi quirtang uh put in
place um
you're gonna get your job by the way
well that's up to the the incoming prime
minister if liz trust is the prime
minister then she'll have to decide her
cabinet do you want to remain chancellor
i will serve wherever uh liz trusts uh
if she's our prime minister i hope she
is the prime minister decides to even if
it's health
wherever she decides you remember what i
have always said to you
you know we we are a team we have to
spend the next 24 months delivering for
the nation um we have to make sure we
help people in this difficult time where
putin is using energy as a tool to try
and divide us both uh domestically but
also divide us as an alliance um i know
you've got to go let me talk to you
about sizable c quickly is that going to
be launched by the prime minister
well he's making your speeches nick
there is ongoing negotiations with is it
a good idea with edf it is certainly a
good idea that we continue to invest in
nuclear you know it broke my heart when
i saw that uh i think it was a meme a
video of nick clegg saying we won't
invest in nuclear because it won't be
ready until 2021.
if we'd made that investment then you
know labor divesting from nuclear under
ed miliband um
those things should have happened if
they had happened we wouldn't be
challenged in the way we are challenged
today because of of putin using energy
boris johnson and i hope uh
liz trust
will make sure that we deliver nuclear
uh both in terms of large nuclear but
then the really exciting thing is things
like the rolls-royce
working with constellation energy the
u.s uh energy company on the smrs these
are the the
future of nuclear uh small modular
reactors and then the
amrs beyond that which are really
exciting we've been talking about them
here
with
our colleagues which is why you're here
yeah i get that so lots of
really important investment decisions
for the medium and longer term but not
to forget that people will need help
this winter and my my pledge to your
viewers is more help beyond the 37
billion will also be coming but we don't
know what it is yet final question
before i must let you go i understand
that um can you guarantee to my viewers
that not one of them
will
find themselves in a position where they
are cut off because they cannot afford
to pay their bills
no one should be cut off because they're
connected
they're because i'm working with the
companies to make sure and ngos of
course to make sure those people who
really are struggling get that help both
financially the 37 billion but the
companies themselves have already
started to write letters and emails uh
to ask people if they are vulnerable if
they're feeling that they can't pay that
they should contact their
supplier their companies
my my pledge to your viewers is that we
will deliver the 37 billion um so that
1200 pounds to the most vulnerable 8
million households but we'll go beyond
that because we know we need to and we
need to send a message to mr putin that
this strategy is not going to work which
is why we have to target the help to the
most vulnerable to allow
us to stretch that help as far as we can
and then of course make sure that we
remain resolute as a coalition to
continue to help ukraine in their battle
they're paying with their lives with
their blood
what we have to do is make sure
we continue to help them mr chancellor
thank you very much indeed for joining
us thank you thank you
okay billy speaking there to the deemed
sahabi in washington and our political
correspondent tamara cohen is with us
now for more on the interview and her
analysis of what we heard there good
morning to you tomorrow so uh plenty to
pick up from what the chancellor had to
say um let's start with him saying that
people shouldn't be cut off if they
can't pay the energy bills
this exclusive interview in washington
dc is intended to show that the
government recognizes that more help
will be needed whoever walks into number
10 next week and nadim zahawi who is
supporting liz trust says more support
is coming in addition to what's already
been announced and she echoes that
herself in an article in a newspaper
today saying she'll take a robust
approach to helping people who can't pay
their bills so a turnaround for her from
earlier on in the campaign when she said
tax cuts would be enough that we're now
looking at strong signals from her and
her camp that there will be more direct
support to households but he stressed
several times there the chancellor that
it should be targeted at the most
vulnerable households to give you an
idea of who those might be at the moment
those households who will receive the
full 1200 pounds that the government
announced back in may there are about 8
million of those households so not the
majority but quite a large chunk of them
everybody gets 400 pounds but that 400
pounds is spread over six months so it
may not feel like a huge amount at the
time the chancellor also said no one
should be cut off by their energy
supplier very few people are cut off and
there's a long process before that
happens but he says he will work with
the energy companies many the big ones
commit already to not cutting off
customers who can't pay their bills to
make sure that that doesn't happen but
when you've got the context of more
reports today suggesting that three
million people this is according to the
resolution foundation will be pushed
into poverty by the energy bill rises
we're expecting over the winter time the
pressure is escalating and he says it's
coming but you'll have to wait at least
a week to find out what support it is at
least a week for that emergency manager
if this trust wins and we'll find out if
what happens if we see soon that wins
and you also mentioned there's sort of
the energy mix that we can expect with
the next administration that comes in um
and focusing particularly on nuclear
energy because of the announcement we're
expecting later today as well yes so
boris johnson is giving a speech today
his last big speech as prime minister
and it's about energy security now it's
in east anglia and it's widely expected
that he will give the go-ahead to the
size well sea
uh nuclear power station in suffolk we
all we know is that he's going to be
talking about the need to think long
term about energy security and you heard
the chancellor there saying look if we
in 2010 had given these nuclear power
stations to go ahead we might have them
on stream now i mean little
simplistic in sense that neither nick
clegg nor ed miliband who he also
mentioned were the prime minister at the
time a nuclear power station was given
the go-ahead by david cameron back in
2016 and at hinckley and somerset and it
ended up taking a very long time and
being very expensive and there are also
big questions about who funds these
nuclear power stations but i think the
the broad direction we've heard from
boris johnson many times is that he
wants to build nuclear power stations so
that we are not facing this huge
reliance on russian gas globally not
necessarily just the uk which is driving
up prices everywhere and so we could see
a big announcement by him today but of
course that will need then to be agreed
by the next prime minister you know he's
he's going out the next prime minister
will have to say whether they support it
too yeah and how it's going to be funded
of course we'll find out about all right
tomorrow appreciate it thank you so much
for that now let's take a look at the
morning's front paper front pages now
and we'll start with the front page of
the eye which is reporting on liz trusts
being urged by colleagues to help
households and businesses immediately
should of course should she win the
conservative leadership race the daily
mirror features the resolution
foundation as tomorrow was just
mentioning there saying that millions
more people will be plunged into poverty
next year and that they'll find their
disposable income falling by around 10
on average
front page of the guardian that leads
with a warning that children could die
this winter if families are forced to
turn off
their heating
but the daily telegraph reports the liz
trust is considering scrapping motorway
speed limits and banning smart motorways
the daily express says that whoever wins
they'll have an audience with the queen
at balmoral not at buckingham palace
that's to save her majesty from a trip
from scotland
well to the war in ukraine now and a
british national who's been named as
craig mcintosh has been killed while
working as a medic let's bring in our
security and defense editor debra haynes
who is in ukraine for us this morning
deborah good morning to you so just
bring us up to speed what do we know
about what may have happened to mr
mcintosh
so his family have released a statement
they set up a gofundme site to try to
raise money to bring his body home they
said that he was killed
last wednesday on the 24th of august
they said that it happened when he was
trying to rescue people from a vehicle
saying that he died in the line of duty
they've said that he's out here he's
been out here volunteering as a medic on
the front line and they say that he was
a hero and they're wanting funds to try
to
bring his body home they said that
because he was out here as a volunteer
the uk government isn't able to help
them
bring the body home
the foreign office has actually released
a statement as well about his case
they say that a we are supporting the
family of a british man who has died in
ukraine and are in contact with the
local authorities and now i understand
that because the foreign office has such
a small presence here in ukraine it's
obviously only limited in what they can
do to help the government has been
pretty consistent since russia's all-out
invasion began
back in february warning people not to
come to ukraine to help the ukrainian
forces on the ground here and instead to
support from back home by raising money
through charity events but of course
many people did heed a call from ukraine
itself to come out here to fight and
also to volunteer there have been at
least three other british nationals
who've been killed two of them dying on
the front line a third man a volunteer
who was captured by russians forces
russia backed forces held in russia
territory and died while in detention
really underlining the serious risks
that are taken by those who come out
here certainly all right deborah for now
appreciate that thank you
now british charities have launched an
urgent appeal to help millions of people
affected by those huge floods in
pakistan the u.n has called them an
unprecedented climate catastrophe shiner
mohsen reports now from sindh
we're traveling along the indus highway
in sindh province between seven sharif
and dardu where we've been reporting
from over the last few days and uh
all this water here this is not a
natural river or a canal this is rain
water from this so-called monster
monsoon it has completely besieged this
area all the homes have water going into
them and the electricity pylons you can
see behind me they're completely
submerged there's no electricity in many
parts pakistan already struggles with
electricity
service and there's no
telephone signal a lot of lines are down
and internet is wishful thinking in many
parts but beyond that it's the basics
they don't have food
and water and shelter the people here
from the this area they've many of them
have moved out of their own homes and
into
makeshift tents some of them
kept back from other
disasters back in 2010 when they had
floods in this area others have used a
piece of clothing and sticks to make
their tents they don't want to leave
their homes they don't want to go too
far into camps or or move along like
we've seen in the last few days other
people have moved to other areas where
they can fly dry find dry land but they
want to stay close to their homes
they're hoping the water will recede
but that also means while they stay
close to this water they are washing in
it they are drinking from it and of
course
there are no bathrooms around here this
is sewage water mixed with this monsoon
water and there is a serious concern for
water-borne diseases
well still to come on the program with
more than 30 million people in pakistan
affected by flooding i'll be speaking to
one of the country's leading
environmentalists
plus britain's intelligence services
wants to boost the number of female
coders in their ranks we'll be speaking
to the boss of code first girls
[Music]
and a little later we'll hear from the
labour party where the shadow of
business and energy secretary jonathan
reynolds is on the show
well it was the 12th and final
conservative party hustings at wembley
last night and the two candidates stood
together at the end with both pledging
that they would bring the party back
together
whoever wins despite what has been at
times a very bitter battle let's get the
thoughts now of mark harwer a former
chief whip of the conservative party
we're supporting rishi soon at mark
harper good morning to you good morning
so much for being with us so i'm sure
you were at the hustings last night um
it did seem as if the mood at the end of
it was at least the party would try and
come back together but how can you do
that to such a bitter bitter battle well
i i think that's right the party does
have to come back together um it will
depend on obviously what happens in the
the final analysis i mean i agree with
what your correspondent john craig said
about the hustings last night i think
rishi sunak
clearly had the support in the room
which is not a trivial thing when
there's 6 000 members in the room
um and i still think it's all to play
for i think the feedback we've been
getting on the streets uh on all the
meetings that he's been to and at the
hustings and we've been getting from all
the phone calls we've been making is
actually not what the polls are saying
and i still remember the 2015 general
election you know when i was going
around knocking on doors getting really
good feedback and the polls all of the
polls were saying that ed miliband was
going to become prime minister so i
think it's all to play for obviously
polls close tomorrow yeah at five
o'clock and then we'll find out the
result on monday he's still confident
that your man could win i mean
in in the event that he doesn't win i
mean there have been some uh quite
cutting things said about liz trust and
her economic policies you know that
she's been taking a holiday from reality
her costume plan is not up to the task
if she was to win how would you guys
then get behind someone whose plans are
so uh out of the ordinary as you think
they are well look i think the positions
we've been setting out during this
campaign i think have been well made i
think rishi's plan which is to
focus on tackling inflation to make sure
we get help to people who are vulnerable
this winter you know you can't help
people on the lowest incomes and
pensioners by cutting national insurance
because they don't pay and she's ahead
in the polls and it's like well she'll
win but but you can't deliver help to
the people that are going to need help
and so i think the problem with plans is
that they also have to reflect reality i
think rish's plan is totally rooted in
the reality that's facing the country
this winter
you know the next few months and i think
that's why he deserves to win that's
what he's been setting out in front of
our members you know any member you know
listening to this that thinks that
that's the best plan that hasn't cast
their vote yet you know they can go
online and they can do that you've made
the future you've been doing that all
the time so look
you're saying that her plans aren't real
they're not going to work
if she was to win how would you be able
to support a budget that she put forward
well i think i think reality is going to
intrude i don't think the plans that
she's set out are going to stick because
they simply don't deliver help to people
i listen to what the the chancellor was
saying this morning in america in the
interview that he's just done with kay
and he's talking about direct help being
needed
but she's ruled out what she called
handouts and she said that she's going
to cut taxes well taxes are great for
people that pay lots of tax you can't
help people who don't pay very much tax
by cutting their taxes and i think we're
going to need direct help so i think
that is what is going to be necessary
whoever wins this contest mr what you're
laying out here is a very fractured
party regardless of who wins the season
if richie sunit wins i mean the people
who supporting this trust don't support
the position that you're taking right
now so as a former chief whip what work
needs to be done to bring the pipe back
together but more importantly what
damage have you done to the party by
this two-month campaign i think the
campaign i think people understand that
during a campaign people set out their
positions whoever wins this and gets
elected as leader on monday is going to
have to to behave in a way which enables
the party to come back together that
means doing what both candidates have
said which is appointing a cabinet from
across the party
all of the talented people in the
conservative party we've got fantastic
talent both on the in the current
government but also on the back benches
it means having an approach that's
inclusive it means listening to
conservative mps when you're formulating
policy to make sure you have policy that
goes into both the red wall and the blue
wall to use those you know convenient
shorthands and it's about the tone of
the government and its approach and i
think both whichever of the candidates
wins will be wise to follow his approach
as indeed okay mark harper will follow
in a few days time whether you are right
or not thank you
hello and welcome back uh our top
stories this morning the chancellor of
the shekel nadeem sahabi has told sky
news that nobody should be cut off this
winter because they can't afford to pay
their energy bills
a new report warns that british
households are on course for the
sharpest falling living standards in a
century
an urgent appeal has gone out from
british charities to help millions of
people affected by the flooding in
pakistan the u.n has called what
happened there an unprecedented climate
catastrophe
now in one of his last speeches as prime
minister boris johnson is to urge his
successor to push forward with plans for
clean energy and is expected to make an
announcement about investment in new
nuclear power that's been backed by the
chancellor nadeem sahari who is speaking
to k burley
boris johnson and i hope
liz trus
will make sure that we deliver nuclear
both in terms of large nuclear but then
the really exciting thing is things like
the rolls-royce
working with constellation energy the
u.s
energy company on the smrs these are the
the
future of nuclear
small modular reactors and then the
amrs beyond that which are really
exciting
well let's bring in our business
correspondent paul kelso for more on
this good morning to you paul nice to
have you with us um so listen there are
plans now to expand
the uk's use of nuclear power are they
realistic and when do you think these
things are going to come online
they're realistic if the government
provides the funding and that is the
question that
i suspect will remain unanswered after
boris johnson gives a speech this
morning he's going to be at size well c
a proposed site of a new nuclear power
station one he is very keen on his plan
was to announce that the government was
fully committed to a 20 stake in the
power station which we built by the
french nuclear provider edf which will
take another 20
with the two parties looking for another
60
from private investment in open markets
it sounds like that
final deal
of state support has not been agreed and
instead mr johnson is going to have to
make do with a commitment of several
hundred million pounds to help keep the
development moving forward it has
planning permission uh that was granted
by the business secretary back in july
but there's been some unease about the
prime minister who's not supposed to
make any big decisions committing such a
large amount of money but it is part of
what was his strategy to deliver at
least a commitment to one new nuclear
power station every year for the
remaining years of the decade the uk
currently has twice as many
decommissioned nuclear power stations as
it does have operational ones and
nuclear is seen as an absolutely key
part of the energy mix to augment the
wind farms that we're looking at now
they are providing uh 20 to 30 percent
of power on a daily basis but of course
they are not running universally at the
moment nuclear power can only manage
about 20 of the uk's needs which leaves
us turning to gas-fired power stations
uh to fill the remainder and right now
this morning 70 of the uk's power is
coming from gas so that gives you an
idea of why nuclear is so important in
the energy mix why boris johnson is so
keen to make it a flagship policy and we
have to wait and see whether he's
actually delivered an element of that
today or whether this is rather more
another stop on his uh legacy farewell
tour
certainly may well be right paul thank
you for now
all right let's return to the flooding
in pakistan now where an area said to be
the size of the united kingdom is
underwater i'm joined now by pakistan's
representative for the international
union for the conservation of nature
that's mahmoud
aktai good morning to you and thank you
very much for being with us
the situation facing your country has
been described as a catastrophic is the
climate uh catastrophe of the decade so
says
the climate change minister sherry
rahman do you agree with her analysis of
what's happened
yes i fully agree this is not only
decade but decades i would say i would
like to add
pakistan has faced exceptional
situation especially the year 2022
has been an exceptional unique year
in the beginning of the year we
experienced
prolonged winter
then
this summer especially
april to
may
months were the warmest months lost 60
years
we experienced in pakistan
a lot of forest fires
taking place in one location where iucn
has done
analysis
and on the request of government of
pakistan prepare this report
over 8 billion rupees loss has occurred
in one of the districts in bulacan
along with one of the incidents and we
prepared a program
uh coming to these floods
and rainfalls this is again an
exceptional
after 2010 that we
received
very very heavy
rains and monsoon especially the
eastward and the
westward monsoon map
and uh
in uh sindh and in balochistan we have
received in guajistan 451
percent
more
rents compared to the not
similarly in
sin we have received
evidence in kpk parts of the kpk we have
received heavy rains and
it's not only limited to this even
mountainous areas glaciers this year we
have experienced 31 gracious sorry
i'm sorry to interrupt you but we don't
have loads of time i don't want to ask
you another quick question about the
situation facing pakistan i mean you've
laid out there just the catastrophe that
tens of millions of people are having to
deal with and also the fact that
previously for a decade or so you've
known that this catastrophe may well be
happening so i i wonder has enough been
done by the government there's enough
funding in place to try and mitigate
these kind of um situations i know this
is quite unprecedented but should more
have been done to try and stop it being
as bad as it is
okay you i think one one thing which has
to be understood is uh this acceptance
situation the government is grossly
undercapacitated the situation i think
is much beyond
the capacity of the government
international
partners when it comes to emissions
pakistan is contributing less than one
percent pakistan is facing uh
huge challenges the vulnerabilities you
know top 10 countries that pakistan is
experiencing these
heavy
flooding situation the institutions that
are responsible need to be capacitated
and i must say
that
they are trying their level best but the
capacity of the
international community that needs to be
made available at the moment we have
national level national disaster
management authority which is working
very hard we have national and the
provincial development authorities but
they need to be
more uh empowered in terms of developing
these
mechanisms or forums that exist i think
need to be further strengthened
institutions that are responsible for
example the meteorological department
we cannot
you know afford to have assessments
that are not precise in terms of they
need to be
impact based assessment done in
partnership with so international
community i think need to come forward
and make best uh efforts
mr sorry to interrupt you again sir we
have we have run short time i do
appreciate your time this morning you've
made your case forcefully and of course
uh another call for greater donations
from british charities has been made in
the past few hours so uh mahmoud
from the international union for the
conservation of nation pakistan
appreciate your time thank you and best
of luck in your work thank you
thank you very much
all right let me bring you some of your
morning's other news now and a
long-awaited u.n report on china says
that that country has committed serious
human rights violations against uighur
muslims in the region of xinjiang
it found that china's treatment of the
uyga and other mainly muslim groups may
constitute crimes against humanity china
has dismissed the findings as lies
the uk government is being urged to put
families at the heart of its policy
making in a new report the children's
commissioner for england dame rachel
d'souza says investing in the family is
the single greatest investment you can
make we'll be speaking today rachel
later in the programme
and the conservative party leadership
candidate liz trust has said that she is
willing to look at scrapping at
compulsory speed limits on motorways she
also pledged to ban smart motorways she
made the comments during the final
conservative party hustings last night
now sky news has obtained new figures
showing that 350 killings in london
since 2002 are unsolved that represents
more than one in 10 killings and
campaigners say that black victims are
much less likely to receive justice lisa
dowd reports
his nickname was bugs
yeah bugs
he was a character a serious character
but he loved his music
he's so handsome beyond brown had just
become a dad when he was stabbed five
years ago i don't know why people behave
in this man i really don't i don't know
why people
i think it's okay
to take something's life
and
just walk away
bjorn's death is one of 350 killings
that have gone unsolved in london in the
last two decades according to figures
obtained by sky news
in march 2017 cctv showed bjon on his
bike in croydon being approached by two
males just before he was stabbed
after his death the grimestar stormzy
tweeted woke up to hear a childhood
friend of mine ain't with us anymore
rest in peace bugs
beyond's aunt a former gogglebox star
won't rest
and um
we will catch the people i know i pray
we'll find them
five years on 10 years on i'm not going
to stop searching
the figures also show that more than
half of unsolved killings in london
involve black or asian victims there's a
massive distrust of police not only in
london but across the country in urban
areas and this just distrust is
particularly uh acute in areas where
there's
either large black communities or or
ethnic minority communities who have had
a historic poor relationship with the
police and i think this does
hinder
policing and investigations
the metropolitan police say that they
assure loved ones that unsolved cases
remain under regular review and they've
renewed their appeal for information
about beyond's murder
lisa dowd sky news
during the second world war many women
had essential jobs all over the country
not least at bletchley park deciphering
the enemy's codes now the call has gone
out again for more more women to work on
the front line of technology as coders
joining me now is the ceo of code first
girls that's anna brailsford for more on
what you're trying to do to get women to
get into coding so just tell us why do
we need to have more women coders
well this is a really unique supply and
demand issue
over the next five years we're looking
at one qualified woman for every 115
roles
essentially we need to get more women
into coding and onto the front line so
they can be makers of our future and to
create the products and the
infrastructures that we need to protect
the country and also to build the
economy as well now when people hear
coding they might get a little bit put
off or scared concerned that they're
going to have to learn i mean computer
code which is another language isn't it
how challenging is it what kind of you
know qualifications background do you
need to get into it so we're quite
unique in our approach uh what we do is
we provide women with free education
and at the moment we're one of the
leading alternatives to the computer
science degree so we don't actually need
women to have any technological
background in order to come in and to
land coding and what we do is we assess
potential
and we give them all the skills that
they're going to need to be able to get
a job in the industry i mean where are
all these jobs because you said one
woman to everyone 150 roles i mean those
149 roles are being filled by men i
guess then is that the point yeah it's a
115 rolls um
um so where are the jobs so we work with
over 100 companies at the moment within
our portfolio we educate the women for
free and essentially we pre-match them
to one of these companies in the
portfolio so all of these companies are
hiring right now just one example that
we have today is within the security
sector and within the defense sector
which is why we mentioned bletchley
parts as gchq and that's working on the
front line of the uk's defense against
cyber attackers etc
it is very much so and women are really
really important
to moving that forward
not least of which because
if our infrastructures our algorithms
our data sets are built by people that
frankly look
and sound exactly the same there's going
to be weaknesses in them it's going to
be easier to hack
um it's going to be um it's far easier
essentially to find holes and weaknesses
in our systems in security you're
suggesting that women might have an
inherent advantage in trying to do this
work than
the men would
it's all in diversity of thought the
more diversity of thought that we can
bring into the creation of these systems
and processes
the more we give ourselves a competitive
advantage um and the greater advantage i
think we have as a nation um on the
stage when it comes to things like
global threats
and and how much is sort of the
encouragement for girls to get into stem
subjects science technology engineering
and maths um has this sort of led to
this point of of having more women
getting into coding well this is an
ongoing issue right how many girls are
in stem
if you look particularly at something
like computing
um the figures um are pretty pretty sad
you know all the way from sort of gcse
where
access to this subject is actually
limited particularly
in potentially disadvantaged areas and
schools in that regard if you look at a
level choices around 80 of all a level
candidates are our boys and then take
that into university around 17 of ucas
applications for computer science come
from women in the workforce that
translates to about 20 of women in the
workforce so
providing an alternative and saying look
it's okay to change your mind once
you're at university or once you've gone
into a career
code first girls enables women to do
that
and at the moment we're well over 600
oversubscribed for women who have the
potential to move into these jobs they
just need the vehicle to be able to
achieve that and you're providing that
for them code first girls they can find
it online i'm sure and i'm sure there'll
be loads of them well looking out for
that anna brown's really loved speech
this morning thank you thank you
hello and welcome back the mother of
olivia practical belle was in a vigil
last night for her nine-year-old
daughter who was shot dead at their home
in liverpool last week it was a dark
hour for the community the church
congregation was told skye's chief north
of england correspondent greg milam was
there in the community she called home
this was a chance to remember those who
knew olivia pratt corbell the neighbors
and friends in the church where she
would have taken holy communion in the
next year
away from the cameras olivia's mother
was among the congregation we can only
imagine what the family continues to
endure but this was those around them
coming together in a show of support
group is a very difficult thing and it
will take them a long long long time to
will never come to terms with what's
going on but they will certainly be able
to suck it in and say that they're not
on their own people here will show
invisible support
the investigation continues police say
they're grateful to those who've come
forward with information but that just
because arrests have been made it
doesn't mean they need that information
any less
close to the scene of the murder
officers were carrying out another
search the firearm used still hasn't
been found
for more than a week now this community
has wrestled with the horror of what
happened to olivia the questions and the
anger and the disbelief but this was a
moment of reflection a moment to mourn
the loss of one young life
and the heartbreak of one family
i hope that the family have gained some
strength from seeing exactly how many
people have come out this evening and i
know the school have got further things
that are going to happen over the next
couple of days so hopefully the family
will get
um
a little bit of strength from that
knowing that everybody is behind them
100
it's just a shame that
something like this happens has to
happen to bring a community together
and it's really really sad
i mean a fifi
you know the young children growing up
today in a place in a cruel cruel world
and i just hope that they get them
next week children will return to
olivia's school without her but with
support on hand so next week is an
opportunity to find out
just how deep the impact has been on the
children and what level of support each
child will need some will need more than
others some will know more than others
they queued to sign a book of condolence
in what the bishop called a dark hour
for this community and one still with so
many questions greg milam sky news
liverpool
okay time now for a look at the day's
weather
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
it's going to be mainly fine again today
but it will be more unsettled tomorrow
and it's going to be very wet and windy
over the weekend before then there will
be a mostly dry start but it will be
quite chilly in some parts of the north
with mist and fog in places the windy
south will be milder and mostly fog free
the morning will be fine with early fog
soon lifting but the odd light shower is
possible eastern britain northern
ireland and ireland are the most at risk
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now you're going to like these these
most detailed images ever of the titanic
have been recorded take a look it's been
nearly
40 years since the famous rock was
discovered at 3
800 meters below the surface of the
ocean now an expedition has brought back
the first ever super high definition
footage of the wreck which shows the
ship at the very bottom of the ocean you
can see just incredible detail
scientists can use the video to help
determine the rate at which the ship is
decaying and identify any species living
on
and around it and maybe they'll find
that necklace that was in the film you
know the one that dropped into the scene
now in the next hour i'll have more
reaction on our interview with the
chancellor nadim zahawi
[Music]